first tonight there are serious
long-term problems facing America as
we've told you about for years on the
show thanks to outsourcing this country
no longer has the same reserve of stable
middle-class manufacturing jobs we did
even thirty years ago in coastal cities
housing has become astronomically
expensive prices are rising far quicker
than wage growth and most tragically an
opioid epidemic kills tens of thousands
of Americans every year one achieve
reasons for that is a synthetic opioid
called fentanyl it smuggled in from
abroad now these might seem like
unrelated problems but they're not a
single theme unites them a systematic
decision by many of our country's most
powerful leaders to sell out America to
China those jobs that were out sourced
they went to China those rising home
prices all cash Chinese buyers are a
major contributor to that though it's
almost never said out loud
fentanyl made in China with a knowledge
and tacit approval of the Chinese
Communist Party China is no longer
simply an economic rival to the United
States it's becoming a dangerous enemy
but instead of protecting us from this
threat an existential one our leadership
class collaborates with the other side
why do they do that simple they're
getting rich from it this only became
clear to many people a few months ago
when the most American of all sports
professional basketball a game literally
invented in a gym in Springfield
Massachusetts ripped off the mask and
showed the world who really controls the
league NBA general manager Daryl Morey
you'll remember wrote a tweet supporting
pro-democracy protesters in Hong Kong in
the resulting backlash the NBA and Mori
both apologized for daring to criticise
china's fascist regime and then lebron
james weighed in and explained to us
that actually freedom of speech in
america is vastly overrated so many
people could have been harmed not only
financially but physically emotionally
spiritually so just be careful what we
we tweet and we say and what we do even
though yes we do have freedom of speech
but there can be a lot of negative that
comes with that too uh-huh just be
careful with what you tweet or say cuz
the Chinese are watching and they pay
the bills Golden State warrior
coach Steve Kerr meanwhile explained
that there's really no moral difference
between America and Communist China it
has not come up in terms of people
asking me about it people discussing it
no nor has our record of human rights
abuses come up either people in China
didn't ask me about you know people
owning air or 15's and mowing each other
down in a mall yeah so America has
school shootings China is on his third
or fourth genocide since World War two
you know tomato tomahto six dozen one
whatever yeah
saying something up like that out loud
should be shocking but it's not really
it's a taste of just how completely the
people in charge identify with China
over this country in some cases they've
literally joined China's payroll former
Illinois Senator Mark Kirk for example
is a registered for an agent who lobbies
for the china-us Exchange Foundation
that's a Chinese organization with ties
to the Communist Party a former senator
former Senator Joe Lieberman works for
another Chinese company ZTE what ZTE
well ZT is so dangerous to American
interests that last August the President
signed a bill banning the federal
government from using that companies
equipment because it's too threatening
but he's lobbying for former congressman
Rick voucher meanwhile has lobbied for a
whole list of Chinese companies
including hikvision Huawei and the
search engine Baidu but China is in
content buying off our retired lawmakers
they're also targeting people who have
jobs that matter right now last night on
this program we told you about a man
called you mang he's the chief
investment officer at California's
massive state-run pension fund called
CalPERS mang who was born in China and
moved here at the age of 25 previously
ran China's 3 trillion dollar portfolio
of foreign investments CalPERS has long
engaged in shareholder activism to
advance left-wing causes in this country
like gun control and been very
aggressive about it but now the fund
also supports China's efforts to eclipse
America CalPERS invests in companies
that supply the Chinese military
literally there also invests in
hikvision which makes the surveillance
equipment that china uses to monitor
ethnic minorities like the we Gers so
they're actively abetting fascism
there's nothing harmless about these
investments as you mang himself once
noted quote of course it empowers the
Chinese regime to have the money flowing
in and quote of course it does but they
did it anyway when men worked for
Chinese investment fund he was recruited
by the thousand talents initiative
that's a Chinese program designed to
encourage foreign businessmen and
scientists and other experts to work on
China's behalf often secretly the
explicit goal is to obtain Western
technology and research for China's own
use so they can surpass us which they
are last month Harvard chemistry
professor Charles Lieber the head of the
department was arrested for hiding his
work on behalf of China in a fact Lieber
was working as a spy but his case isn't
special the entire sleazy academic world
and it's one of the sleaziest is
addicted to Chinese money Harvard and
Yale both stand accused of hiding
hundreds of millions in donations from
payments from foreign countries
needless to say China is one of the top
contributors recently the Texas A&M
University System tried to gauge how
many of its faculty were getting Chinese
money more than a hundred of them had
been recruited it turns out but only
five had reported their work for a
hostile foreign government how many were
indicted you guess oh yeah zero now
Chinese officials aren't paying these
academics because they love scholarship
no America's universities are key
centers of scientific research and
technical innovation China would like to
steal that information and they are as
of tonight the FBI is investigating more
than a thousand cases in which they
believe China has stolen research from
American firms if anything our top
colleges and universities are
encouraging this to happen and you can
see it by the way they recruit Chinese
grad students fill our research labs
this makes college administrators much
richer but it also allows the Chinese
government easy access to critical
information some of it that directly
bears on our national security the
American academics have made it clear
whose side they're on
last November officials at the
University of Missouri Kansas City
removed an artistic display supporting
protesters in Hong Kong because Chinese
students complained according to the
Republic Columbia University's global
center
Beijing canceled talks because they
might upset Chinese officials they're
squelching free speech at the direction
of Communist China and that's common in
the business world
Disney changed its de Benton character
in one of its movies into a European
woman because acknowledging Tibet's
existence would anger their masters in
China they should be ashamed gap
apologize for selling a t-shirt in
Canada that didn't feature Taiwan as
part of China by the way it's not part
of China but China demanded that gap
pretend it is and they complied we could
go on their endless examples of this
kind of thing it's happening all around
us so how about Michael Bloomberg he's
running for president maybe more than
anyone in America
Bloomberg represents the beliefs and
values of our current aristocracy which
is by far the worst in American history
the stupidest the most greedy not
surprisingly Bloomberg has both kowtow
to the Chinese and gotten rich from the
Chinese he's not embarrassed by it
in 2014 Bloomberg explained that
actually China's unelected leader isn't
really a dictator the become his party
wants to stay in power in China and they
listen to the public when the public
says I can't breathe the air shaping is
not a dictator he has to satisfy his
constituent so he's not going to survive
it he's not a dictator no he has to he
is a constituency to add to answer to so
the Chinese dictator is not a dictator
it makes you wonder how Michael
Bloomberg would govern as president or
maybe it explains how he'd govern as
president but Bloomberg's personal
admiration for the bloodthirsty fossil
in charge of the world's largest
communist country isn't the only reason
he likes China there's big money at
stake of course that's always what it's
about
Bloomberg's company has enormous
investments in the country and that has
influenced how Bloomberg News reports on
China in 2013 for example Bloomberg News
was accused of killing stories that
would have revealed corruption by family
members of the Chinese dictator and yes
he is a dictator
Ben Richardson Bloomberg's Asia editor
later said he'd been told directly by
leaders at his company that covering the
Chinese Politburo was off
that's like telling a Washington bureau
chief you can't cover Congress because
you might insult them that's Michael
Bloomberg's position just today former
Bloomberg reporter leta hung Fincher
wrote in the intercept about how
Bloomberg's lawyers threatened to
destroy her life if she wouldn't sign a
nondisclosure agreement about the
company's censorship practices but don't
take their word for it a few years ago
Bloomberg openly admitted that he let
China's censor his company's news he
actually said that on television here it
is over the past year there's been
questions about the journalism going on
in China and whether the company in its
effort to grow has muzzled in China they
have rules about what you can publish we
follow those rules if you don't follow
the rules you're right not in the
country we write the stories that we
think are interesting and we distribute
them where they are allowed to be
distributed where they're allowed to be
distributed the scariest part is that as
China has grown more powerful America
has grown more dependent on it
outsourcing our manufacturing power
brought American companies big
short-term profits head to Florida and
you'll see the houses they built with
those profits but in the long run that
decision made this country dangerously
dependent on a nation that seeks to
displace us on the world stage consider
just one small sector of the American
economy medical supplies China is now a
top producer of antibiotics surgical
tools prescription drug ingredients face
masks and many more essential products
that you need to stay alive 80% of our
antibiotics right now come from China
hard to believe but true the coronavirus
panic alone was enough to cause
shortages of some of these materials
what will happen in the if an even
bigger crisis comes along as it
inevitably will or what if trying to
simply cuts off exports as a show of
force that could happen maybe they
invade Taiwan and then cut off exports
how do we respond
we'd be helpless the saddest and most
infuriating part is that none of this
needed to happen in the first place
China didn't just one day magically
overtake us our leaders made that
possible they abetted it they profited
from it they betrayed us